face à la pression des parlementaires
donald trump ratifie finalement le plan
de relance jusqu'au bout il aura menacé
d'opposer son veto à ce plan daide qui
prévoit 900 milliards de dollars destiné
à aider des millions d'américains
durement impactée par la crise du
comique 19
après des mois de pandémie si l'économie
américaine est en souffrance
le locataire de la maison blanche
énumère les différents secteurs qui ont
besoin d'elle je ratifie cette
législation pour restaurer les
allocations chômage
arrêter les expulsions locatives
apporter de l'assistance aux bailleurs
ajouter des fonds supplémentaires au
programme de prêts aux entreprises
permettre aux employés de l'aérien de
retourner au travail et donner des fonds
substantiels en plus pour la
distribution des vaccins
après de longs mois de négociations ce
plan du congrès le résultat d'un accord
entre démocrates et républicains
donald trump souhaitait jusque là le
modifier en triplant le montant du
chèque prévu par américain le faisant
passer de 600 à 1800 dollars un souhait
qui n'a pas pu se concrétiser
en conséquence les allocations chômage
dans un premier temps suspendu pour 12
millions d'américains précaires vont
pouvoir être versée du côté de
washington la satisfaction est quasi
unanime
je salue la décision du président de
faire passer des milliards de dollars de
secours cruciaux contre le kobe 19 entre
les mains des familles américaines
je suis heureux que le peuple américain
reçoivent cette aide indispensable alors
que notre nation continue de lutter
contre cette pandémie
parallèlement donald trump a signé la
loi de financement de l'état fédéral ce
qui devrait permettre aux services
publics de rester ouvert